they will be met with fire fury and
frankly power the likes of which this
world has never seen before
Rocketman is on a suicide mission for
himself and for his regime do not
underestimate us and do not try us well
that was just a few months ago
remarkably how do we get from that to
what we're watching right now on our
screen Byron York has covered all of it
he's the chief political correspondent
at the Washington Examiner and he joins
us tonight
Byron reverse-engineering the the long
road from there to where we are right
now how much of this was intentional how
much of this unfolded as a plan or a
strategy on the part of the
administration well there was a strategy
to do something new I mean this is so
extraordinary because it is a president
trying something new Donald Trump is
criticized for virtually everything he
does but he has been perhaps criticized
a little less for this because North
Korea is a problem that no president has
been able to figure out ever before
anyway what was kind of striking if you
go back to the 2016 campaign for all the
time that North Korea has taken in the
Trump presidency it wasn't really a huge
thing in the campaign it wasn't a big
thing in the GOP primary debate yes nor
in the general election debate and I
think that what what Trump is doing here
is something so new because in the
campaign for example he he would
criticize and pledged to undo what a
previous president had done like the
Iran nuclear deal or he said he would
not engage in foreign venture ISM like
george w bush but this is something
completely new and now maybe there's a
reason it's never been done before it
was a bad idea we'll find out but this
is a president who was willing to do
something different than his
predecessors very quickly since you
you're part of the press but you also
watch carefully how do you what do you
think of the news coverage of this well
I think that as I said before I think
it's been a little less negative than
than a lot of other Trump things because
there's a possibility this could work
and and so while there's a lot of sort
of a natural tendency to poopoo what
Trump does I mean this actually might
work I think a little bit of it has
gotten caught up in the coverage of the
g7 coverage in which you've had a lot of
news commentators suggesting that Trump
is trying to destroy the Western
alliance and then go dust goes weakened
in the Singapore but generally I think
in the lead-up to this while there was a
lot of criticism of some of the things
you just played Donald Trump saying this
rocket man and the fire and fury stuff a
lot of criticism of what he did there
but when it actually came to the idea of
an actual summit I think people are
waiting to see what happens it's
impressive
Byron York thank you Thank You Tucker